- Good morning Believe Nation.
Today we're going to talk
about how you can live life
without regrets.
As always guys as you're
watching the clips,
if you hear somebody say something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
Also when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick with yourself too.
Enjoy.
(gentle cheerful music)
- The biggest poison in us is regret.
It's poison.
And I push so hard, so hard,
and will through my vehicle,
which isn't meditation, which
isn't health and wellness,
which isn't non-profit.
My people's business, I can't help it.
It's what I love.
I love building businesses.
I love competing with
you, I want to beat you.
I love that game.
But through that vehicle,
I will always push
a lack of regret.
And awareness to how good it really is.
You're more than welcome
to me about how bad it is
or why you can't because or
what, but it's just not true.
Because if anybody ever
did it, then you can too.
Stop making excuses.
Stop complaining.
Nobody's listening.
They may pretend they're listening,
the market doesn't care.
What you need to do is
make one person happy, you.
Then you can make everybody else happy.
You know why I like making people happy?
'Cause I'm already happy.
And so I implore you to
take this last little rant
and really look at your
face and understand
are you doing the things that are putting
you in a position to succeed?
Not just in the business
world, but in life.
Because it's super important
because boy, when you're happy in life,
your business can roll.
- We walk around thinking
people look at us
as the star in our movie, but they don't.
Everybody else is living the same dream.
They're walking around the
star of their own movie.
And we're just a film
extra in their movie.
So if we stop and taking the actions
that we think will lead towards success,
because we think we're worried about
what the good opinion of
other people will do to us,
I got news for you, so listen carefully.
I don't get on my soapbox
about many things,
but I'm getting on it about this guys.
Nobody cares enough about you
to bother to give an opinion
because they're too
busy being worried about
what they think you're thinking of them.
Failure, failure is not taking the step.
Failure is not picking up the bat
and swinging it at life.
Failure is getting to the end of this game
and regretting what we didn't do.
Failure is about saying what if.
Failure is lying on
your death bed thinking,
oh well if I only I could go
back and do fill in the blank.
You know something?
To me, failure isn't falling down.
It's staying down when you've fallen.
You have to fail by the
definition of oh I didn't succeed
in order so you can succeed.
That's what life is about.
It's not about taking it with at the end,
it's not about score keeping.
I've probably failed
more times than I've won.
But I keep my average
number of tries high.
And do you know what happens?
Guess what?
You tap into the lesson of
history that most people ignore.
And that is this, it's
the paradox of history.
That those that will
risk the least in life
usually end up with the least in life.
Just because our brain won't tell us that
when we have to pay
our mortgage on Friday,
doesn't mean it isn't true.
So get up and get in the game.
Who you are right now watching this
is as a result of your
failures not your successes.
It is when we're tested.
When the storm is ripping
the branches off our tree.
And when the rain clouds are there
and we think we've got nothing left.
That's who we are at our best,
when we show up when we're tested.
The strongest trees grow
in the strongest winds.
Not in the best soil.
So next time you have an opportunity,
next time you start to question
whether you should step forward or not,
will it be a white
square on the chessboard
or a dark square, who care?
Get in the game.
Swing the bat.
Be all you can be.
Get up and if anybody
says, oh you're doing that,
or oh you did that, oh look
it you failed, know this.
They're failing in their judgment of you.
Not in your ability to pick
up the bat and swing it again.
That's the person you were
born to be my friends.
Alright, that's the person who you are.
You were born a miracle,
you are good enough.
You don't need me to tell
you that, you already are.
Get out there, get in
the game, go embrace it,
and if you fall over, pick
yourself up, swing the bat again,
and let's go play this game of life.
- When I decided to do this,
I first talked to my
wife who is sitting here
in the audience.
And she had married a
relatively stable, goofy,
but still relatively stable person
working at a Wall Street firm.
I worked at a quantitative hedge fund.
And this was a hard decision.
And I was looking for the right framework
in which to make that kind
of important decision.
And the right framework I found
is a regret minimization framework.
And that's just a nerdy way
of saying that you want to
project yourself to age 80.
And then think back over your life.
And if you're 80, you want to
minimize the number of regrets
you have throughout that period of time.
I think this is something
a lot of people do.
Maybe subconsciously,
very few people probably
name it regret minimization framework,
because most people are
healthier than that.
But it was a very clear
way for me to think
about making that kind of life decision.
And the way it helped was I thought, okay.
If I go do this thing and
participate in this thing
called the internet,
that I genuinely believe
is going to be a big deal, and if I fail,
am I going to regret
having tried and failed?
I knew the answer to that was no.
But I also knew that if I didn't try,
that I would always regret that.
I would always wonder
and it would haunt me
until that mythical day.
- One of the greatest problems in life
is that we don't forgive
ourselves for the mistakes
that we've made.
We carry them around and we
beat ourselves up about them.
But understand this.
The person who did those
things in your past
is not the same person that you are today.
In fact, you are a
completely different person
with different experiences
and different knowledge
and different wisdom
and different insights.
The person who did those
things that you still regret
is not you.
It was a younger version of yourself.
Almost like another person altogether.
So let yourself off the hook.
It's alright, everyone makes mistakes.
- Whatever's happened
has happened I'm afraid.
Deal with it.
I don't want to deal with it Ralph.
That was me on my early journey.
I have worked in a lot of shoddy jobs.
And for a long time, I
was preventing myself
from becoming my greatest version,
hanging around with people,
not living a lifestyle
I'm living right now.
But if I think back and say, gosh actually
I shouldn't have done that.
I could've done that.
I would've done this.
What does that change?
You see we often think that if
we think longer on a problem,
it's going to change it,
but thinking doesn't
actually change things.
Only radical action.
So what's helped me along
my journey is to say
okay, yeah.
A lot of my past isn't the best,
but a lot of it is.
You see it's always a
matter of what you focus on
when dealing with the past.
It's that emotion that's like
can I get a hello?
A lot of us we only focus on
not being good enough at that period.
But right now, we're totally different.
Okay so what's helped
me is to realize that
whatever's happened has happened.
My only concern right now is where am I?
I'm in nature, baby.
And there is only right now.
- That I think the best method
to avoid fear or regret
at the time of death
is while we are alive.
Our time, our energy must
utilize meaningful way.
Serving of that, that's like most
(speaking in foreign language)
way of, meaning of usefulness.
Monsoon survivor, even
animals also can do.
But for service to other
is something unique about human being.
I think (speaking foreign language)
the mother and child or offspring--
- [Translator] The bond.
The bond between mother--
- Bond.
Even other animals also have.
But that kind of closer
feeling should be it.
But we, human being,
because of intelligence,
that kind of feeling we
can prolong, hold our life.
- [Translator] Yeah,
extend it through our life.
- So, serving other people.
Helping other people.
It's the, I think, very very
appropriate sort of action
according our intelligence
of human ability.
We have special ability.
So to utilize that ability
(speaking in foreign language).
- [Translator] The most appropriate way.
- Oh, most appropriate way
is serving other people.
Then at the end, you feel no regret.
I done my best, some useful
sort of meaningful life.
Now I come, although
sorry, sad, but no regret.
- So I'm with Jeff Bezos on this one,
I think the best way to live
your life without regrets
is to imagine yourself on your deathbed
looking back at your life
and looking at the situation
that you're in front of right
now and asking yourself,
am I going to regret not doing this?
Am I going to regret saying no?
Am I going to regret being afraid?
Because if you are then
you know you have to go out
and do it.
For me, that's what saved me.
Whenever I'm in a situation
that I'm afraid of doing,
it's not don't be afraid.
'Cause I'll be afraid,
it's okay to be afraid.
But the thing that gets
me through the fear
is that bigger fear of regretting
it later on down the line.
And being able to make that
mental leap inside your head
to understand the short
term thing you're feeling
is fear and you don't just
disguise it with a reason.
'Cause there's always
a practical reason why
you shouldn't do something.
There's always a logical
reason why you shouldn't do it,
and if you can get through that
to understand that that's
not actually the real reason
why I'm not doing it, I
can deal with those things,
I could fix those problems.
The real reason is I'm just afraid.
And then if you think about
your life at the end of the road
looking back on it, for
me the best way to do it
is to work on building that muscle.
For anytime you're afraid
of doing something,
start building the muscle.
At the start you're
going to be really weak,
just like anything else.
When you start lifting
any kind of weights,
you're really really weak.
But as soon as you find yourself
being afraid of something,
try to train yourself to push through it.
And so I've told the story about
when I was wearing different colored socks
because my son Hayden, seven years old,
was wearing different
colored socks, always has to.
And so I wanted to one day
wear different colored socks,
but I was afraid of what
other people would think.
And as soon as I recognized
I was only not doing it
because I was afraid of
what people would think,
then I had to go out and do it.
I had to build that muscle.
Or the time when I'm
walking down the street
and I'm dancing and grooving
'cause I got songs in my ear.
And I love it and I'm vibing.
And as I get closer to
a main intersection,
I shrink down and I'm just doing this
because now all of a sudden
there's people around.
And most of the time we shrink
down without even noticing.
It's so subconscious, it's
so natural to shrink down.
It's so natural to play the smaller game
because you're concerned
about what other people think.
And as soon as I caught myself saying
wait why am I playing
the smaller game here,
why am I so afraid?
Why am I concerned about
what are these people
going to think if I'm
bustin' out some dance moves?
So as soon as I recognized
I was holding myself back
because of the fear of
other people's judgments,
then I had to go and dance bigger.
I had to go and groove
it out on the street.
And dance.
And build the muscle.
And so anytime you catch yourself
doing something and the only
reason is because you're
afraid of it, work on
building that muscle.
Because the last thing
I want for any of you
and the last thing I want for myself
and the people around me
is to be on my deathbed,
however old that's going to
be, looking back on my life,
looking back on this moment and regretting
that I played small because I was afraid.
Build your muscle.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Ghita asked me to.
So if there's a topic
you'd like me to cover
in the next edition of Believe Life,
leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd love to know what did
you think of this video.
What was the clip that
inspired you the most,
what did you learn from
this that you're going to
immediately apply somehow to
your life or to your business?
Leave it in the comments below,
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I'd also love to know how do
you live life without regrets?
What are some of your strategies
that maybe haven't been
covered in this video yet
that you want to share
that may help Believe Nation
and the people watching as well.
Leave it down in the comments
and do a good public service.
Finally I wanted to give a quick shout out
to Thelma Saunders.
Thelma, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and posting
it to Twitter as well.
I really really appreciate the support.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, have an amazing
day and I'll see you soon.
- I don't think I would change anything.
Because I think it's
important to go through life
without any regrets.
People have said to me,
would you change '98, would
you change the red card
against Argentina?
Do I wish it hadn't have happened?
Of course.
But if it hadn't have
happened, would I have been
the player that I am today,
would I have been the
strong person on the field
and off the field that I am today?
So there's nothing, nothing I regret.
- Everything happens for a reason.
How many times have people told you that
and it's really annoying right now?
Don't tell me that.
Now why do people say this?
Because subconsciously,
we know it's the truth.
What helped me along
my journey was to start
connecting the dots.
I now realize everything
that I went through,
everything I've gone through,
has led me up to where I am today.
I got to thank those shoddy jobs.
My irresponsible behavior.
And it's going to continue to
be very irresponsible right?
It's going to continue
to be very irresponsible.
There are no saints here, baby.
This ain't the Brady Bunch.
Okay?
So you got to have a sense of humor,
you got to realize that okay,
everything you are going
through is preparing you
for the next step.
It's what I call coming off
your righteous high horse.
Now I share a lot.
And it's very introspective,
that why I always say
this is what's helped me
along my journey.
Everybody has to realize
nobody has it all figured out.
Even though I'm a psychologist.
I inspire millions.
I'm still evolving.
But I realize if I can realize that
it's okay.
The past is okay, even
if it's really grimy.
Even if you want to put a
blindfold on, that's fine.
But realize, that was meant to happen.
Why? Because it did.
There are no accidents or
coincidences in this universe.
Everything is in divine
order, I accept that,
I'm not in resistance to that.
Powerful mantra, right there.